so what I'm gonna do here is as I
usually do it I'm going to assume that
the statement is true for it equals k so
assume true for N equals K so I'm just
going to rehearse the line with cases
that it ends we've seen this before
nothing - here's my assumption and
that's just my first monthly I don't
have to do anything to that now I want
to get into my proof which is the next
case okay so here comes the proof step
I'm gonna do my substitution and I see
there's gonna be a k plus one over here
and it's gonna be a plus one okay
so how do you set about going fitness
now like I said there are two different
ways to do this importantly because what
I'm about to start is a proof I need to
start from something that I've
established is true okay so for instance
a lion I can't start with is this lion
right this should be my last line can't
be my first one right which is why I
often put these three letters out the
fun which you see me do oh never again
to highlight for myself you can't prove
anything off this you're trying to prove
this so when you have a look at your
entire bore and you're like whoa what
will my starting point be the only thing
that I inverted commas know to be true
at the moment is this line okay so this
is going to my starting point where is
room we're having a look at life these
guys here right if you have a series
like the question we did in the quiz you
take this and you just start to
manipulate the left hand side okay I
will show you a way of doing that later
on but for now let's start from
something I know and this is here okay
so I'm gonna write this down
okay now remember the reason I'm
starting from this is because of the
inductive hypothesis so I need to state
a reason for it
so I'm gonna say by assumption okay
now where am I trying to get to there's
a few different paths through this but
you can see probably the simplest way
from this lesson to something like this
is on the left hand side I notice but
the difference between what I've got and
what I'm trying to get to is a factor of
12 do you agree with that like that's
what this means this is 12 to the K
times 12 so I'm going to take both sides
of this inequality and multiply them by
12
okay I can do this because 12 is a
positive number so my in popular quality
stays intact doesn't change direction or
anything like that now I'm gonna have a
look the left-hand side is exactly what
I want it to be yep so that's really
really good
cool I can ignore the left-hand side now
I don't know work exclusively with the
right now what I'm trying to get to or
something like that is this but that's
sort of where I'm headed okay
but what you need to understand is if I
want to prove like suppose this was
actually a number like oh I don't know
say like 10 okay I want to prove that
something is bigger than 10 okay if I
can prove that it's bigger than like if
my final line here has a 10 in it cool
but if I have something bigger than this
like say 11 or 12 or a thousand then if
I'm bigger than a thousand I'll be
bigger than 10 as well right does that
make sense so what I want over here in
the right hand side is either this or
something bigger than that does that
make sense that's what I'm aiming for
now when you look carefully something
bigger is exactly what you've got
remember just like we saw this is 12
lots of 12 to the K this is seven months
of 7 to the K and this is five lots than
5 to the K now I have them here right in
fact I have more than that to make it
clear because this is a proof let's pull
out seven of them right so if I have
seven of my seven of the case here well
I actually have another five don't I
then 12 breaks into these two parts so
I'm going to put this guy there five
over here on the right hand side okay
here I can break this up as well I only
want five of them I only need five of
them so if I break out five of them here
well I've still got left over this donut
how many left over others there are
seven of them
what's your trance again
okay do you see what I've done maybe get
some colors out so you really really
clear on what's happened here this 12
lots of 7k I've broken into on these two
pieces yes and they're 12 lots of 5 to
the K I've broken into these two pieces
you with me
good we're almost there because what
I've got here right is 12 to the 12 to
the k plus 1 is bigger there now look at
this right this is 7 to the k plus 1 and
this is 5 to the k plus 1 and then
you've gotta put a big set brackets on
it all of this stuff remember what I
wanted on this right hand side is either
this or something bigger than this and
I've got this plus some extra stuff
right so if I'm bigger than all of this
I'll be bigger than this by itself does
that make sense
so my next in pretty much my last line
is therefore 12 to the k plus 1 is
bigger than the thing I want as the
reason why I can say that is because
this thing is making the whole thing
bigger right of course if it was
negative this wouldn't apply it but I've
deliberately crafted so I can see it's
not okay as this part over here the
extra bit is positive if it were
positive my logic green hole okay
another way you might see this written
sometimes is you have this second last
line here right and I'm don't write this
down because it's gonna cloud up your
butt a little bit but some people put on
the end there
well but that is also in turn bigger
then this for the same reason right so
it's like oh if a is bigger than B which
is bigger than C well that means a is
bigger than it's a lot bigger than C or
whatever it is okay so you'll sometimes
see that notation and I'm okay with that
but as you guys know I try and avoid
having the wiser games once
so I kind of prefer this okay and that
was it was the guts of the question okay
we have gotten into the k plus one okay
so therefore I'll say true for N equals
k plus 1 and my final line proven by and
then you go okay now how do you feel
about that as you went through this okay
for instance particularly in just
retired four questions when I got to say
yeah right okay when oh my god in what
direction do I go I suggest that we
start with the assumption okay because
at least I know it to be true but then
we had to do some manipulation here now
I wonder for you like how obvious did
that manipulation seen and once I had
done it how clear was at what direction
you should go in now that you've seen it
it's family well I've solved this puzzle
now so I can reassemble this one quite
easily but next time you'll have
slightly different logic here right so
how happy does your mind sit with this
not everyone likes this method I will
mention the main reason why I've done it
this way is so that because I mentioned
this last time so that I don't have to
muck around with this assumption I've
assumed it I didn't have to alter it in
any way and I could use it directly in
this sort of mechanism okay